this is weird we've got a sovereign
fleet approaching from the rear why
would they do that
probably because Rockets stole some of
their batteries od right you didn't
steal some of those I don't know why
they're after us what a mystery this is
what were you thinking dude they were
really easy to steal that's your defense
come on you saw how that high priest is
talking down there was not a generalist
why doesn't realize your motivation was
altruism really a shame the sovereign
mistaken your intentions and they're
trying to kill us
exactly I was being sarcastic oh now
you're supposed to use a sarcastic voice
I'm a fool and you put the bickering on
hold until after we survive this massive
space battle coming good I'm gonna kill
some guy
hope you're ready it'll be here any
minute got a rifle you do know what a
rifle looks like it's just sort where
you're thinking and gun for mine but I
guess we were both doing guns out I just
didn't know that that's intense
I see it within you fear jealousy
betrayal is about you to cleanse the
universe of its weakness you know they
told me you people were conceited
douchebags but that isn't true at all
dude I'm using my wrong I put your seat
belt on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so with taming the galaxy again we're
really going to be able to jack up our
pricing for two-time galaxy Davis
[Music]
our first
[Applause]
sometimes the thing you're searching for
your whole life it's right there by your
side all along your right family
so maybe her
after all these years I've found you and
who the hell are you I'm your dad Peter
[Music]
you